tropical depression Cindy is on track to
bring drenching rain from the
Mississippi River and Ohio river valleys
to parts of the East Coast the storm
caused widespread damage on the Gulf
Coast after making landfall in Louisiana
spun off a series of destructive
tornadoes there one rip through an
Alabama town collapsing buildings and
spreading debris david beg no is in
hard-hit fairfield alabama with the
latest there David good morning so this
was an oil change location there's a
fast-food restaurant in here there were
a couple of vehicles actually being
serviced when the roof collapsed this
happened at high noon yesterday as
tropical storm Cindy was being
downgraded to a tropical depression in
our weather coverage over the last few
days we had told people that there was a
chance for tornadoes what makes this one
rare is how strong it was the winds were
up to 110 miles per hour but get a look
at this as the tornado blew through here
it blew the roof off a liquor store but
look at the bottles they're still on the
shelf as if untouched
tropical storm Cindy is to blame for
spawning the tornado that carved a path
through Fairfield Alabama just outside
Birmingham drone footage shows the
widespread damage the tornado ripped the
roof off this building but left those
bottles still neatly stacked on the
shelves four people were injured one
driver narrowly escaped serious harm
this covered my head and start praying
and when I lifted my head up once I
realized it had passed over there was a
wood stake through my windshield the
National Weather Service estimates
roughly twelve inches of rain fell in
some spots along the Gulf Coast since
Tuesday the storm has claimed one life
ten-year-old Nolan McCabe he was killed
in Alabama on Wednesday he was struck in
the head by a large piece of debris it
is flooding that remains a danger for
many people like those in Biloxi
Mississippi slide we got the rain from a
hurricane we just didn't get the
hurricane and Gulfport we're Larry Jones
took us through his neighborhood which
has seen flooding dozens of times
the years how much do you think the
waters come up I would say at least
seven foot from where it's normally at
okay we spotted several people who
decided to hunker down at home and just
ride out the storm why would you stay it
might be like this for a few days you
know me and my husband and my son your
father we have all our whatever we need
we prepared for you know we have a food
everything and back here in Fairfield
Alabama the tornado threat continues
today for this very area Fairfield and
the Birmingham area for the most part
what was Cindy has moved on north and if
you live along the Gulf Coast and Cindy
didn't affect you good but remember
hurricane season just began June 1st we
got all the way through November 30th to
go nor alright David thank you